What are some other natural ways to reduce eye inflammation besides the
rife? I've been doing the rife and it has helped.
So one of the things that you want to look at, whatever you have, okay, I have
eye inflammation. The first thing you want to ask your question,
ask yourself and you probably already have is why?
So why do I have eye inflammation? Was there an irritant?
Did I, was I exposed to something? Is it a histamine type reaction in my eye?
Meaning like an allergic reaction, we're at that time of year where,
you know, that's a possibility where there's a lot of allergens in the air.
Is it something else that I have used a cream on my face or something like that
that could have been an irritant? So do ask that question and kind of put your
Sherlock Holmes hat on and see if there was anything that caused that inflammation.
There are some nutrients for eye issues that people have purchased on our store.
I don't know the validity of all of those things. I know in the past that I remember,
actually it was one of my first cancer patients ever way, way back in the early, in the late 90s
that her friend came in with her and she had a blocked eye duct and they were going to actually,
she was scheduled for surgery and she had a bunch of swelling around her eye and they were going to
go in there. Actually, she was explaining to me the surgery that they have to literally go in there
with a drill bit to drill that out. And this is what we did right in the office and I actually said,
well, let's do the right one and let's see if that helps. And actually we did the right one and she
came back with her friend the next visit, which I think was like two days later and she said it's
all gone. She can't hold her surgery. I mean, just one treatment with the right made to open up to that
duct. So if you have, you know, there's other causes to it, there's other issues that you can
have with an eye that could be in infection. So if you have bacterial infection or viral infection,
you might want to address that and address that with the right. So if you're running the right
on just inflammation that will help with inflammation, but still not addressing the reason why,
because the reason why a person could have inflammation is because of the virus or because of the
bacteria. So you'd have to do a little investigation. I don't, I don't off the top of my head know
the most common eye bacterial infections and what bacteria it is. But if you did Google that,
just Google the most common bacterial eye infections or viral eye infections and then whatever
that comes up in that Google search, you could just run that program on your right because most likely
your right has that bacteria in the list, in the alphabetical list. If it's thought that it's
a virus, then you could run the viral program as well. So there's just a viral complex program on the
right that may be extremely helpful.